Prince Harry and Megan Markel's first
royal tour down under continues let's
talk about this for a second
he T was on hand as the royal couple
made their rounds first stop the shores
of Sydney where they bonded with the
locals on Bondi Beach
they've been amazing we had a group hug
you know it's Prince Harry Megan the
whole one wave crew and a group hug and
he was so open and they were so friendly
with everyone and it just felt like you
they were our best friends Megan and
Harry spent quality time with community
surfing Group one wave which raises
awareness for mental health it was the
best thing ever you know to have Prince
Harry and Megan down it and their bright
colors part of the one wave family it
just made mental health visible around
the world and showed that no matter what
you're going through you're not alone
just put your hand up talk to someone
ask for house hello City Australia hello
Invictus then the couple geared up for
the 2018 Invictus games cycling and
sailing competitions we're a fantastic
team we no real except this time Megan
was noticeably missing from the
festivities after multiple reports claim
Kensington Palace decided to cut back on
the expectant mom schedule Prince Harry
stepped out solo to greet athletes where
et caught up with him
Harry how you doing how excited are you
for the game very excited how exciting
you
37 year-old Megan joined Harry in the
afternoon looking lovely in an oversized
blazer and black turtleneck at a
reception hosted by prime minister Scott
Morrison per usual the parents to be
looked thrilled to greet children from
an organization that supports kids
living in families affected by mental
illness the Duchess of Sussex hasn't
slowed down much since announcing she's
expecting her first child on Monday
pregnant Megan cradled her baby bump
while walking hand-in-hand with Prince
Harry as the couple explored Fraser
Island in Queensland Australia
Harry eventually made a solo appearance
to help with the unveiling of the
Commonwealth's dedication for the forest
of Fraser Island one of the few times
Megan has taken a moment to rest it is
up to us now to protect this paradise
together not just because it looks
beautiful but because it is an essential
part of our existence and will continue
to be for our children and their
children's children they are a very
conservation minded family so the fact
that they're there and interested in our
wildlife and hopefully will be able to
do more work together in the future
ET spoke to Steve Irwin's family who
happened to be in the US while the
Royals toured their home country bindi
Terri and Robert are proud of the work
Megan and Harry are doing to help
wildlife they're good people doing good
things and we certainly wish them all
the best and I think they are I think
they've had a little koala action well
again they're meeting a koala that's
very important so yeah
very happy
[Applause]
you